hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
alors avant d'accueillir nos invités on
va d'abord accueillir le brocoli du jour
c'est valérie bénaïm vous voulez je vous
êtes dans les rimes amiens mais c'est le
méga là on va super bien
non mais c'est un très beau visage oui
et non mais c'est vrai et là ça vous va
super bien sûr sénégal ouvertement on
est bien d'accord du tout très belle
comme ça mais je vous en prie les
invités vont être contents d'être à côté
du brocoli ah non mais regarde non mais
regardez là sans rigoler c'est très très
lourd en fait c'est très symbolique au
havre